hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is a woman with a very intriguing
and very unusual profession because
alexandra calla and she here she is is a
perfumer that is someone who creates and
markets beautiful irresistible and
exotic perfumes and it's great to have
her here on talking germany welcome
thank you wonderful wonderful i'm really
looking forward to it now i have no idea
exactly how many perfumers there are
here in germany or indeed around the
world but it's not many and alexandra
calla stands out because she works for
the manufacturer of the legendary four
seven eleven or de colon
alexander the first question
uh how many perfumers are there in
germany i was just saying to the
audience that i have no idea not so many
i have no clue about the exact uh
figures no no no do you have any idea
how many there are around 500
approximately 500 so you are one of 500.
well i'm i'm more a perfume developer
a fragrance manager like an evaluator
who creates together with perfumers so
i'm the translator in between the
marketeers and um the perfumers so
talking in the perfumery language this
is more the way i'm working yeah so
what does that amount to what do you do
on a day-to-day basis um
i work on projects like
next
possible lounges
for our house and i work together with
the marketeers on on the concept we
discuss together how they select
the ideas and then i try to translate
them in all effective families like okay
is it more
a light spring version or will it be an
oriental very heavy uh sexy
sophisticated perfume and then we start
to think about possible ideas and i
smell a lot all together with my
colleagues on blotters on skin yeah and
then i develop and fine-tune the ideas
so you're not a perfumer but you are i
mean
you have to admit that you are a nose
that your nose is very very important
the nose is my potential in fact
otherwise i couldn't your potential it's
your now yeah yeah
is it insured your nose no it's not it's
not insurance no
it's like a pianist fingers you can't
afford to lose your nose that would be a
pity in fact it would make me
sad as well how uh how early in your
life did you discover that your nose is
about
500 better than mine well in fact it
wasn't me it was during interview in a
fragrance house um ah this story yeah
yeah tell me
we had a normal interview yeah um and
then i had to do a smelling test i was
not prepared on that
but when it started i really fell in
love with it because i got more than 20
different lotus with
raw materials on it yeah and i had to
describe them the way i was able to do
it
and i also had to do a triangle test in
terms of
triangle test smelling three times the
same raw material in different dilution
that means they wanted to know
how
how
deep i could describe and to find the
difference in terms of this is strong
this is less strong and this is
the weakest this is what they wanted to
figure out and this is when you talk
about people
who could smell better than others maybe
because everybody could smell but there
are more some people who are maybe you
might have a tattoo i i just i simply
don't believe you that you didn't know
before this oh really
i was sensitive you were sensitive my
parents they they
my mother especially she said well you
why don't you want to go into that room
uh it's a normal smell inside and said
no it stings i cannot go into it this
this came up and my father before
starting to eat he always starts to
smell the things but i personally
had no special um
no special sign for me it was normal are
there substances are there fragrances
that you particularly adore
i love flowers you love flowers and the
special
special synthetic materials which smells
between a transparency like a morning
dew and mixed with slightly
floral petals this is gorgeous and are
there any fragrances or smells that have
you sort of recoiling that you want to
be away from it as quickly as possible
well uh cold smoke
i i totally hate especially when it got
into your clothes and in the in the hair
transpiration is
not that nice
raw materials in fact i really there are
several ones i don't like but it's
important to have those materials as
well because they make a composition
special so i wouldn't say i hate this
one maybe i hate it when i had to smell
it singular
okay
you've had your first impressions there
from alexandra keller
now it is noses to the fore actually
gives us an olfactory introduction to
the city that she has made her home and
that city is cologne
i mean petals they are so fragile and
i admire them because the fragrance they
transport is is fantastic and so it was
like like a bath although it was on the
ground on on a hard sole but it was
fantastic feeling i couldn't stay there
longer wonderful what's the difference
between a smell and a perfume
a smell for me could just be a molecule
so a single raw material and a perfume
is a final composition is the thing you
you put on skin as an accessory it's
like like you put on your your shirt
your your dress your uh jacket and
during the day and um this is
everything to to fulfill your outfit
your style your okay so so it's a it's
it's it's a fashion choice and a fashion
statement in many ways it's actually
interesting what i was because i i know
very little about perfume i have to say
and i've been reading around it for the
whole of the past week and uh and i saw
one description of perfume described as
um liquid emotion
you like that yeah i like that yeah okay
that works in fact we talk about uh the
juice what is inside a bottle is the
juice the juice the juice
that sounds very juicy
what's the difference between a good
perfume and a bad perfume everything is
so subjective um i couldn't answer that
directly because for for you um
a heavy woody
uh intensive smell might be horrible
because you you connected it with bad
experience in the past and for somebody
else it could be heaven on earth so it's
really tough to say because it's so
subjective and for everybody different
take us back a little bit in history
you know people you're saying it's a
fashion statement now but way back when
a hundred years ago or a thousand years
ago
they had different purposes yes they had
tell me they in fact they had nothing
else there was a period where water was
not a good thing to use because people
they didn't wash themselves so so they
were happy that they could use the
fantastic nature things like like flower
flowers in terms of pomades like solid
perfume to put under there uh how do you
call the perutin the wig
right yeah and or to put it in in the
clothes
or as um on on the wrists uh just to
smell good because they they didn't want
to to to use water
and so afterwards i mean people were so
happy to use those materials to to make
themselves feeling better
it was also i mean people simply didn't
wash very much that's it truth be told
yeah
um you don't apparently wear perfume at
work right why not because it it would
confuse me it distracts yeah i have to
test or i do test perfumes the whole day
so i need clean arms even body lotion is
not a good because normally body lotion
is
perfumed as well so i had clean arms and
i can test the
the perfumes on my skin but i prefer to
smell on other people because it's it's
different when i smell on my skin than
on other people so to judge perfumes i
always smell on colleagues you're
wearing perfume now though i guess yes
you're not at work this is leisure right
okay
so i'm fascinated to know now where
when you
left
home earlier today what what uh
what what kind of sense were you trying
to literally sensed were you trying to
create
with the perfume that you have applied
um i during a day especially in that
period of the year i prefer to have
those light fresh things i love
the aqua colonia style i have mandarin
catamount on my skin because it's fresh
but also with a woody back note which i
really like
and i don't want to to have an
overwhelming order on my skin so i
prefer a light version okay
i knew you were wearing a perfume
because i picked it up before the show
yeah okay yeah um you create we heard in
the report you create perfumes in your
head how does that work um i mean i can
think about smells and i i reconstruct
them and i smell them when we talk about
woody sands for example i could smell a
sandalwood a set of wood wood wood or
whatever and then i tried to combine
them in terms of in what direction do we
do we want to go with that
new idea
will it be more sportive more
more uh central and so i
i really smell those things in my mind
and all the ingredients yeah do they
come to you or do you go to them how
does that work yeah because a lot of
these are i mean they're nearly all
natural substances
they are natural but also synthetic and
it's always a mixture of both of them
otherwise the composition would be a bit
boring so the the contrast and the
facets in a perfume are really
both
natural and synthetic some of them they
even do not exist any longer in that in
nature and we do not want to explore
nature so it's very important to use
those materials which are the most
exotic which are the most expensive
materials that you have in this
selection of 2 000.
natural ores is very very expensive
because it's um coming from the wood
it's not the flower the petals you take
it's it's the root yeah and the plant
has to be one year old then it ages the
root has to be aged three years and then
it will be distillated so you can
imagine the process to get the essential
oils already long and it costs a lot of
money it's very
very interesting from in terms of
affective smell and of the of the
present so
very special one yeah and you as i
understand it like like a tennis player
or or or whatever a concert pianist you
you sort of practice every day
you train up every day how do you do
that i mean i smell more than between 60
and 80 different smells per day
sometimes less because also
administrative things belong to my
my job
and i really need to do that because
otherwise well i miss it yeah
and on the other side i um i got out of
training and this is important
and we we we learned that you have a
selection of like 2 000 cents and
possibly more at your disposal how many
of those if we were to sit down over a
couple of days and you were to sort of
test them all
and whether you you know whether you
were to get them right how many would
you get right how many would you get
wrong it will well between 200 and 500.
you would get right yes
okay yeah the other one i mean they are
so some have a sort of
slight different touch and and that
might be very difficult or the naming is
different
okay
time now to focus on four seven eleven
we mentioned it already it is of course
the legendary eau de cologne that is
manufactured by moira and verts the
company that alexandra cala works for
and the unique fragrance is this year
celebrating the
222nd anniversary of its creation so
before we talk we have got this report
it's a long tradition alexandra just
give us in your own words give us a
description with all your expertise of
what the actual you know what what we
what we smell
when we have eau de cologne you smell a
combination of a citrus and
aromatic herbal accord the citrus part
consists of bergamot
citrus oil
sweet orange
and then you go to the bitter orange
tree where we got the neroli it's the
flower part
and petigra coming from the
leaves and and um
uh
yes exactly and the aromatic herbal one
is um rosemary and lavender and those
make the smell is it typical has it
changed how people use odor colon
from
222 years ago to today i mean
in very formal days they use it as a
fragrance water they wouldn't have to
talk about a perfume and they put it in
their handkerchiefs and they they smell
it like this they take a deep breath or
they they put it under the ears or in
the decollete or on the other pulsing
parts on your body and then they enjoyed
the the moment as a ritual
they did it in order to feel more more
refreshed or to calm down
but it changed i mean i i remember you
know when i was growing up as a as a as
a young lad yeah i i can remember oda
cologne you know somebody would spill
their coffee or something and
the cry would go out bri get the elder
cologne yeah we need to deal with the
problem it was sort of kind of a wonder
weapon that could be used for anything
people would drink it even yes it was
called agua mirabilis in former days
and um
before um it became a
perfume or a fragrance water it was
really used as a medicine to to to take
it for for your inner and outer health
in terms of a kind of disinfection
because rosemary has as benefits um this
disinfective part antibacterial because
in former days people do not have any
things and the alcoholic part itself was
well kind of medicine as well
and does this explain why you need to
have ha i mean you've had huge image
campaigns trying to sort of you know
turn things around and that was because
not not just you'd lost a lot of ground
it's here yes and i think it's important
to talk about that i mean it's it's
still a kind of um
fragrance water with benefits and we
want to take it over to to to a new
generation who also like this
aromatherapy way in in a way of wellness
or how you would like to call it
nowadays but it's still important and
people really like to use uh fragrances
in terms of different moods they have or
to get into different moods they want to
have it's interesting that we call it
column yeah yeah the sort of the you
know the because france is so central to
the tradition of perfume manufacturing
and perfume making is there a german
tradition of perfume making that you can
really identify you can say that is what
the germans have brought to perfume
making history
i'm not sure i think it's really very
french in a way also when you you as you
just mentioned or the colonial eau de
parfum it's very french and i think the
french language also gives a lot of
wording um to describe perfume so it's
it's more french than german i would say
when you talk about the uh the field
that you work in to what extent are you
working at a man's world traditionally
the developers of perfumes have been men
it changes nowadays it's changing yeah
yeah yeah i don't know if it's half-half
but there are a lot of
female
perfumers in this business
um
also young perfumers and well we will
see how this will end it it's maybe the
to um you can compare it with the with
the cooks because this changes as well i
i have the uh the impression
so
let's see who has the better sense of
smell men or women women yeah
that's the reason that's the interesting
thing yeah you're telling me it's
changing that women are sort of slowly
catching up but they've actually got the
better sense yes they have yeah that's
always my impression yeah when you know
in every situation where with women
there are very rarely men who can
compete yeah
tell me about your range alexandra that
you've you you've been developing you
know
colonia is really um to target more the
people taking care of their like they
they like the wellness idea the
aeromother political idea like your day
spa we have different color codes like
you can see here for different moods
a lemon and ginger version where we want
to to focus on two ingredients with all
of
the variants out of this line and then
we build a perfumistic structure around
so you have this freshness of an eau de
cologne
plus a perfemistic
dress i i always like to talk in in in
terms of fashion because it's like like
an accessory or you use it in this way
more or less for yourself
to feel better to get down or to get an
energy kick
so we have different variants and like
the orange one is cardamom
and mandarine
the dark green one is blood orange and
basil so you have um different types and
the color codes they talk already to the
people in terms of some people could
consider oh yes yellow that might be
citrus and fresh when i look at a
combination like for example mandarin
and cardamon that seems to that seems to
fit in with what you know my reading of
the situation is that the the global
trend has become much more exotic
in recent years even sort of north
american latin american european
manufacturers are looking to asia right
new trends yeah
i mean here within this
line you can really see like a journey
from
europe to as you mentioned asia brazil
because the raw materials are coming
from different parts of the world so we
really try to uh to tell a story around
um
a huge travel trip getting the best
materials
with wonderful benefits from all over
the world in fact
i'm very old-fashioned alexandra i i
don't like it
i know what you mean i mean
good
everything is already like overwhelmed
in in a way yeah but maybe it helps
because smelling is such an unconscious
process and um well the the retailers
they do it for example to to make the
people or the consumers feeling more
happy maybe they stay longer in their
shops and they buy things they haven't
had on their shopping list so this is
the idea behind but it's interesting
sitting at this table we have two people
who are you are sophisticated and i am
naive because until i started reading
about all this i didn't really know that
this was happening to me yeah and then i
start reading about you know that there
are grocery stores who will they they
have you smelling bread baking but
there's no bread baking or coffee being
roasted so you'll go and buy some coffee
yeah it's not
i'm not happy with it yeah
you must notice this a lot when you go
into stores you must see those little
sort of devices
um in fact i didn't care about them i no
i'm more than uh well i'm more sensitive
to the nose than to the eyes so i'm
taking more care of what how i feel when
i'm in in the shop and if i don't feel
well i really go out
i read somewhere that one
one of the top uh retailers in the world
i'm not going to mention the name of the
company yeah apparently their turnover
or the like note the likelihood that
people would buy their products
increases by 80 percent if they use the
right kind of fragrances does that sound
right to you
a little bit of an expert in the field
it's it's exactly you mentioned the the
example with the fresh baked uh things
or the roasted coffee beans this makes
people in a good mood and they they get
into the shopping mood like they buy
things they haven't had in mind they
stay longer and then they are more
relaxed and if you're more relaxed
you're happy and you you feel more
tempted
to to get things maybe you don't really
need but you you buy them and then you
come back again
i told you i was all i'm old-fashioned
has anybody ever come to you and asked
you if you want if this is an area that
you want to work in
no no no
it all works so very well because of
something called the limbic system
yeah
that's right that's right totally right
in the limbic system there everything is
stored combined with emotions and
historical things or the things happened
in past and if you connect the emotions
you have to certain situations with a
smell then you maybe feel like oh i'm
i'm again six years old sitting on my
grandmother's uh bank in the garden and
uh having a lovely um cheesecake or
whatever so this is how we decode smells
when they come up into our nose and this
makes us feeling happy or sad or angry
or like i i don't like this person
because i i cannot stand smelling him or
her
this is interesting yeah this thing
about i can't stand somebody because i
can't
the expression in german is this can
initiation it's a wonderful german
expression the english equivalent is
more or less that person gets up my nose
i really you know i can't stand that
person how important is scent and smell
and fragrance for for human interaction
i think it's more important than we
really know or really
uh are aware of because um this happens
in in in in seconds
um and and you you maybe you cannot
explain because there is no or there was
no sit in not a situation where you said
well he was not or she was not angry
with me or nothing happened but you
cannot explain there is a chemistry you
you we also talk about
hear me in between people yeah uh and if
this is not right uh well you don't want
to get in contact or you don't want to
stay or or listen or whatever with this
person
and if it is right then it's not love at
first sight it's love at first smell yes
just tell me there's this amazing story
about you in your home city of cologne
apparently in your early days as
somebody who was developing their sense
of smell your sense of smell you would
uh
follow people around town yeah
right and you had a notion that they're
probably wearing this that or the other
you'd actually go up to them and tell
them yes
to tell them ask them this was in my
training session when i really uh get
trained and i had to recognize fine
fragrances so perfumes you can buy in
retailer shops and i really follow the
people and then if i was not sure i said
okay
i'm on the shoulder yes
sorry
just a question and and it makes me so
happy when i got it right and it was a
very special experience to do that to do
that because to feel that the sense gets
even more um more intensive you're a
fanatic
a fanatic fanatic for fragrance
yes that's true
that's too
okay one of the five senses is the sense
of smell we know that much another that
is also very important for alexander
khaler is the uh his sight the sense of
seeing and
alexander is a great fan and
practitioner of photography however she
shuns modern digital photography
preferring to use more traditional
cameras with real film the kind of film
that is still manufactured and sold by
small companies profiting from a
thriving niche market
well before we talk about the niche
market just tell us about where your
passion for photography came from in the
first place alexandra oh i it's really
difficult i cannot remember when it
actually started but um i have a huge
selection of albums
at home so to in order to document my my
trips my journeys or even a birthday
party or a trip through the the my own
city um whenever i i go out um i have my
camera with me
um
and i i really like to take all of the
things i i really saw without arranging
them
just to get the moment uh i'm in and i i
realized to to pick it up into a picture
okay you mentioned the moment there but
first of all what what's the you're one
of these people who says there's a
problem with digital photography i've
spent the last 10 years sort of getting
used to digital photography and
accepting it what's the problem with it
well i i actually don't like it it's so
you can do a lot of things with it you
can um
when you put manipulate the pictures
whenever you want to okay you can do
that with a normal camera with the films
as well but um i don't like that way i
really like to to do it more um with the
traditional one because i think it's
more like a ritual as well and that's
why i really like it i'm watching your
hands while you're talking it's a little
you like it to be a handicraft yes a
little bit yeah where do you develop
your your photos then do you do this at
home no i i really go to a laboratory i
do i'm not doing it on on my own
um i really like to to to get or to wait
for them i'm a very unpatient person but
um i really i'm like okay how long does
it take two days three days well with
black and white pictures you have to
wait more than
10 days meanwhile because there are not
so many laboratories doing that but then
i it's like being so nervous in fact to
to get to see the pictures and and this
is why i like the way to take pictures
as well because it's not like okay i can
see a select now this is not nice out or
once more because i don't think that
this moment will be the same again there
you are the moment again yeah
are you one of these photographers that
sits and waits for the moment
yeah i mean i'm not that one
but i when i when for me there is a
perfect i don't i do i do i do it with
my digital camera okay wow and i i
prefer to walk around and then for
example when i see something which hits
me yeah i cannot explain i really have
to take this picture and i love this
speaker lumen when you have collection
yes this is what i really like
tell me about your you mentioned your
collection of photography tell me tell
me about what you you know
what you've got in all these albums
um or different pictures i i make like
like a like a story um to really to um
go again through the vacation for
example after several years it's so
funny sometimes when i'm just searching
something in my my apartment i got an
album and and then i sit down and oh yes
10 years ago oh i was there and i saw
this beautiful monument and we had such
a
such a nice moment a lot of fun and this
is where where i really got into the
moment like with all the senses i have
to get into to this memory and this is
why i love to have the albums and not
digital in a way on on computers and
look through that and do you have a
collection of traditional cameras
no i don't have i don't have okay
um and do you buy the the thing we had
here was this interesting that this in
the report about the film stock do you
actually you order your film stock on
the internet no no no i i go and buy
them there's a very store there's a very
special store in cologne where i always
can get and they have the films i i want
to have also black and whites which are
very rare
so no what's the connection between uh
between being a perfumer and photography
both is very artistic in a way and both
captures things you you cannot explain
or you like them or you don't
it's very subjective um and it's to
catch a moment and this moment can be
can be hold for a certain period a
perfume maybe seven eight ten hours a
picture a bit longer and and you see if
it's an old picture if it really um gets
different reflections already because
it's old or it got too much light on the
on on the image or on the picture itself
this is what i like yeah it is very
interesting because i i as i say i've
been reading up a lot on perfumers
around the world
really interesting people and and one of
the common things about them is that uh
is is that they tend not to be only
specialists in their own field
that's perfume but they tend to be
artistic people who are doing other
things too is that your impression as
well yes yeah i i think you need a kind
of creativity i mean creativity is a
huge word
but um
um i i i'm very interested in a lot of
things like like really handcrafted
because perfumery for me as well is a
handcraft yeah and so um yeah i think i
i like to to create things
including for example jewelry including
for example rings tell us about your
ring because i asked we would like to
ask our guests to bring along a
cherished possession and this is one of
yours tell me about that i i started to
do or to create to design and to create
jewelry i think meanwhile have a look
properly 14 years ago yeah and this was
my first piece yeah which was quite
tough my teacher from
former days told me but um as i i came
up with jewelry which was special
already she said okay try it
it's not that perfect but it's very nice
it's very nice i like the interlocking
design i like the way yeah that's that's
that's lovely and it's really like you
have something in your head and finally
yeah and finally you have something
which you really can have in your hands
in perfume you you don't have but you
have it on your skin and it surrounds
you so it's different but similar
okay we've got time for the quiz at the
end of the show we don't have much time
so we'll whiz through it when you're
making perfumes do you prefer sweet or
spicy
spicy floral or fruity floral simple or
complex complex
traditional or modern modern do you
prefer seeing or smelling smelling
which city smells better berlin or
cologne
for me cologne because it's my hometown
i am convinced berlin smells better than
cologne yeah
um
is it for you a great thing to have a
very highly developed sense of smell or
is it a curse it's a great thing
i prefer to
to have all this beautiful
smells around and to get them and to to
really
stand the ones i don't like and it's the
balance is like
the good smells are higher and more
intensive than the the bad ones so very
happy with that good for you wonderful
thank you for talking about it she's got
a much better sense of smell than i have
here i will never know the answer to
that question okay that is all the time
we've got left for our uh guest here on
talking germany today alexander akala a
woman with an exquisite nose thanks for
joining us come back next week cheers
you